yeah I came to this via playing I eric g
from from Norway right yeah yeah
improving on the flags okay so we have a
banker or Olga gambit playing a sideline
with Knight f3 and Quincy to but I have
fun decent results with that and maybe
this one night will arrive on c4 anyway
at least I hope interesting
okay so i could take now and bishops III
y'all want let's get rid of this
fianchetto i checked out bishop okay
yeah it's a it's attacking the queen but
is it doing much good here yeah what is
he doing here don't understand it really
I take play rook see one or the other
one hmm this is okay and then night see
form a 98 maybe can play Queen a six
then or queen bee five
hmm hmm this is in qiyam probably what
this was until great
ok so I go here yep again no we cannot
play cannot play refurbish should be 20
came hmm yeah I'm taking them before we
do was a bad idea and rather unnecessary
as well
hmm okay Roxy one he can play but should
be tuned game that Sam let's simplify
hmm so yeah he's got this Bishop on g7
which looks rather strong in connection
but only in connection with rooks on the
board a pure minor piece and game would
be excellent for me because of his pawn
weaknesses so he's probably trying to
prevent 94 down I do it anyway intending
knight c6 now at night XP form and I
don't think the last couple of moves
were too successful for black the rock
doesn't really belong here at least I
think maybe no nevo sfio SF 96
maybe you should play rook c8 and online
c6 just say just a sacrifice the
exchange it's probably at least an idea
I don't really see how I can play a very
very passive fashion like look back to
see seven and nine ninety-six bishops
III but that's not really in the style
of a banker player he's still doing it
so look see to Ormoc see one this one
threatening night before yeah still not
before right or a form
your night before i can i can just play
that right
also knight c6 is coming with a tempo
let's say place a cannot play the rook
yeah okay and then I probably already
winning here at least with good
technical plain black resigns yeah and
that's not move I am just threatening 96
or rookie see to this really went
downhill quickly here he up like is
perfectly all right no I no doubt about
that but here he starts he starts some
some bad plan problem Brooksie force
it's not helping at all be three years
and this is really bad simply because
the the bishop needs to have the
opportunity to go to c3 covering of this
this pawn this this was probably all
right or better provoking b3 and then
something like this this this should be
a perfectly okay for black I don't think
I'm worse I mean that it could it could
seem that white as worse and I think
this kind of setup is is perfectly okay
I'm threat I'm covering everything and
maybe I can activate the King later and
or 91 d3 so I don't know yeah but Black
Flag is better yeah our blankies better
yeah as mentioned i am i played it i
didn't play it warm I joined I shouldn't
take before it's just a bad move I think
at least I should I should may play a
look-see one or something first and keep
this this idea in the position with the
time at betim something like this here
is an idea okay you can play that move
but it's not the end of the world
I don't I don't like this in retrospect
this this had this problem this is a bit
a bit of a bit of a problem in this I
didn't calculate that but i just looked
this kind of thing looked looked ugly so
Luke see one was played no maybe maybe I
should go here even and try for that
yeah this is much better you actually
it's important yeah interesting alright
thanks for watching